La volta al món a peu, dia 245.
A punt d'agafar l'AVE des de Tashkent fins a Bokhara,
que és pel que he llegit per ahir la millor manera de viatjar pel país.
Està molt lluny Bokhara d'aquí, són 8 hores,
però aquest tren triga només 4.
No sé si es pot qualificar com a AVE, però sí, és molt ràpid.
El meu vagó està ple, m'han dit.
Que vagi a un altre, que no passa res,
i a més jo he comprat la classe econòmica, evidentment,
i m'obgradeixen gratis a business.
Bó!
Són les 7 menys 3, surt a les 7, a veure si va puntual.
Jo mai agafo l'AVE, però la gent que agafa l'AVE sempre es queixa que la gent parla,
així que intentaré parlar ara, abans que surti el tren.
Sempre estaveu fent una mica de resum, per si algú ja n'ou, no?
Estic fent la volta al món a peu,
i l'altre dia vaig agafar el meu primer avió des de Tbilisi, Georgia,
fins a Tashkent, fins aquí, fins a Uzbekistan.
El motiu?
Bé, intentar que no m'enxampi l'hivern,
a Asia Central, que és impossible caminar perquè hi ha temperatures de menys 10, menys 20 graus.
Ara estic, faré uns dies de turisme, de turisme, de motxiller,
perquè estic esperant el visat de Tajikistan,
i també perquè no sé si mai tornaré a Uzbekistan,
i crec que, doncs, està bé poder-ho visitar, no?
Teniu més informació a aquest vídeo que vaig pujar sobre la meva ruta a Asia.
Llavors vaig arribar a Tashkent.
Tashkent no és la part més interessant del país,
per tant, per això vaig directament avui al matí a Bokhara,
que és una de les ciutats que m'han dit que, doncs, està superbé.
I després ja veurem, perquè, bé, estaré mínim dues nits i després ja veurem.
Bé, una passada, això de viatjar amb business.
M'han portat a esmorzar,
te i cafè.
Una passada, el tren, comodíssim.
No diria que és AVE perquè no va molt ràpid,
però ha fet molt poques parades i, per això, ara, en 15 minuts, ja arribem a Bokhara.
Molt igual tota l'estona el paisatge. Aquest també serà desert, desert, desert.
Però bé, diferent.
Plou foc.
Fer turisme en aquestes condicions, no sé, farem turisme d'interior.
M'aniria bé un paraigües d'aquests antiu B, eh?
Aquí sí, perquè és que és com molt sec.
A l'ombra, no s'està malament.
El que sorprèn més d'Uzbekistan, especialment, venint d'on venim, és el seu paisatge.
Quan mires un mapa, t'adones que la immensa majoria del país és desert o semidesert.
El més gran de tots, el de Qizil Qum, un dels més grans de tota l'àrea central.
No tot el país és així i hi ha zones que tenen rius, de les muntanyes que vagin del Kirguistà i Tajikistan,
i gràcies a aquests rius s'han desenvolupat les principals ciutats del país, com Teixquén, Samarkanda o Bukhara.
El contrast és molt curiós, especialment venint en el tren, en el que passes de paisatges completament desèrtics a camps verds de només uns quants quilòmetres.
Aquí ja arribo a Bukhara i el primer que en trobo és això.
Veureu que la majoria d'edificis tenen la mateixa estructura, que és el Mahó vist,
i després les cúpules d'aquest color turquès.
Aquest edifici en concret havia sigut en l'antiguitat l'entrada a una madraça,
que vol dir institució educativa dintre el món islàmic i, més en concret, àrab.
Just davant de la madraça aquesta hi havia una botiga amb souvenirs de l'època soviètica.
Hi ha un apartat que tenen postals i em plantejo comprar-les, eren molt antigues i em penso que, bueno,
doncs, encrobaran.
4 euros perquè aquest país és barat, no?
Doncs no, doncs no. Agafo 3 o 4, li pregunto el preu i encara que regatejo una mica no baixen dels 5 euros.
I home, doncs no.
Com és un dels primers llocs que veig de Bukhara, em penso que a tot el país el turisme estaria relacionat amb això,
amb tota l'època soviètica, comunisme i tal, però no, no, no, no.
De fet, és el primer i únic lloc on veig tot això.
Començo a arribar al centre i això és flipant.
Ja el primer que en trobo és això.
Pum.
Aquests mítics arcs que hem vist a totes les fotos, dibuixos de la Ruta de la Seda i coses així,
rectangulars, alts, amb aquests arcs acabats en punta i aquests colors blaus, turqueses.
Alguns dels interiors d'aquests edificis avui en dia són restaurants, no a aquesta hora.
Però més a la tarda.
Botigues d'artesans que venen souvenirs i teles i vestits i coses així.
Souvenirs, però amb una mica més de gràcia.
I mans de nevera també venen, eh?
Hi ha un personatge molt famós a tot l'Orient Mitjà i l'Àsia Central que es diu Nasreddin, que és aquest d'aquí.
És una mescla entre un filòsof, un bufó i un mestre de la ironia.
Surt en milers d'històries i contes curts.
Que fan gràcia, però també donen alguna lliçó de la vida.
És un personatge que probablement no va existir mai,
però al món islàmic hi ha molts països que es pensen que va néixer allà i era seu,
com Turquia, Uzbekistan, Iran, Azerbaiyàn, Kazakstan...
Bukhara és una de les ciutats habitades més antigues de l'Àsia Central,
amb més de 2.500 anys d'història.
Potser no és tan coneguda com Samarkand, però també va ser una de les grans joies de la Ruta de la Seda.
L'edat d'or de la ciutat arriba al segle IX, fa moltíssim,
quan va ser la capital de l'imperi Samanida.
Però, tres segles més tard, l'any 1220,
les tropes de Gengis Khan la van conquerir i la van destruir gairebé per complet.
Les llegendes expliquen que, després d'entrar a la Gran Mesquita,
Gengis Khan va declarar:"Jo sóc el càstig de Déu".
El que és un càstig de veritat és la calor que fa.
És època alta, és època baixa de turisme, perquè no s'hi pot estar.
O sigui, aquesta hora, pel carrer, m'estava marejant de la calor que feia.
Crec que és el lloc més càlid que he estat a la meva vida.
I com podeu veure, no era l'únic, els carrers estaven pràcticament buits.
Això és un lloc molt turístic, hi hauria d'haver molta gent.
I no, no, no, no, perquè la majoria venen a la tardor o a la primavera.
Ben fet.
Per la gran destrucció que va provocar Gengis Khan, Bukhara va reneixer
i va continuar sent un dels centres comercials i religiosos més importants de l'Àsia Central.
El seu centre històric conserva més de 140 edificis protegits,
entre mesquites, madrasses, caravansarais i mercats.
Us està agradant?
Doncs jo en aquell moment estava flipant i el millor encara estava per arribar.
Però ja en tinc prou.
Vaig a dinar i després a l'hotel.
De veritat que m'està fins i tot marejant.
Recordeu que a Tbilisi vaig treure dòlars i vaig canviar dòlars?
Doncs ostres, que bé que vaig fer, eh?
Encara no havia canviat a Soms, Uzbeks, que és la moneda d'aquí,
però els establiments turístics a molts llocs accepten dòlars.
I, en aquest cas, em van donar canvi en aquesta moneda tan xula,
que són els bitllets d'Uzbekistan.
M'estic una bona estona a l'hotel descansant i esperant que passi
les zones de més sol i, quan arriba el capvespre, torno a sortir.
A part de venir comerciants de la Xina i de la Índia aquí a comprar i vendre seda,
això, al segle IX i X, era un dels grans centres de coneixement del món islàmic.
Aquí s'hi construïen biblioteques, escoles, madrasses
i algun dels intel·lectuals més importants del món islàmic es va formar aquí,
com Avicenna,
considerat un dels pares de la medicina moderna,
els llibres del qual es van estudiar a Europa durant 500 anys.
Aquesta és la plaça principal de Bukhara.
Increïble, brutal, espectacular.
Especialment en aquesta hora del dia, la posta del sol...
És que... no sé.
No sé. A mi em flipa.
I, de cop i volta, mentre es badava, passa això.
Veig uns guiris, pensava que eren guiris, mirant-me molt fixament, dic, bueno,
estaven sorpresos perquè... perquè això...
Estava gravant i tal, i resulta que són catalans.
I tant, sí, sí, sí.
Christian...
I Núria.
I em vau descobrir ahir. O sigui, casualitats màximes, no?
Justament ahir, mirant vídeos d'Instagram, ens va sortir.
Vam estar mirant 5-6 vídeos...
Però a més, no anem a vídeos d'Uzbekistan, perquè encara no els he pujat.
No, no, no. Crec que estaves per... per Georgia.
Sí.
Sí, sí, sí. I mira, ens vas enganxar, vam mirar 4-5 vídeos,
ens va quedar la teva cara, i t'hem vist amb el tripó del terra
i... caminant davant de la teva càmera, i hem dit, hòstia,
ens sona aquest... aquest noi.
Crec que estic gravant bé.
Què, què feu? Viatge a Uzbekistan, així, o què?
Sí, estarem una setmana voltant per Uzbekistan,
i el dilluns agafem un vol i marxem a Kirguistan.
Un parell de setmanes...
I estareu menys calor que aquí.
Menys calor.
Perquè és brutal.
A qui se li ha corregut venir a Uzbekistan?
Jo no tinc el terreny, però a vosaltres?
Jo crec que és el lloc més calorós que he estat mai a la meva vida.
Bukhara.
Sí, sí, fa molta calor.
Bueno, fa calor al migdia, a la tarda sí que és cert que encara està més fresquet.
Ara està bé. Bé.
S'aguanta.
Acceptable. Acceptable. Sí, sí, sí, sí.
Molt bé. D'on sou?
Molt bé. De Barcelona.
Barcelona. Perfecte.
Tothom encantat, tu.
Molt bé. Bueno, a seguir l'aventura i...
Gràcies.
I aquí surti tot bé.
No hi ha lloc del món on no trobis un català, tu.
És increïble.
Un altre pòrtic d'aquests, molt ornamental.
És que és brutal. És brutal, Bukhara.
Em sembla un dels llocs, una de les ciutats, més aviat,
més maques que he vist mai a la meva vida.
De la volta al món a peu està fred a fred amb Dubrovnik,
però encara em queda un Dubrovnik, jo crec, sí.
El fet que estigui el mar al davant li donava un plus.
Surto una mica de la ciutat antiga i em trobo una mesquita, entre cometes, de veritat,
on hi ha gent que va a resar.
No gravo, evidentment, a dintre, perquè estaven allà.
Però també molt maca aquesta, eh?
Mireu, amb els sostres de fusta i tal.
Però ara sí, hi ha una cosa que sabeu bé,
que he estat posposant setmanes i setmanes.
Ja clamava al cel.
Toca anar a tallar-se el cabell i a afaitar-se la barba.
Sí, sí, sí.
Busco al Google a veure què trobo i vaig a la primera.
La primera, que està més a prop, no em complico.
Però, per casualitats, crec que vaig a la barberia més cara de tot Uzbekistan.
11 euros en cobren.
Que no és tant, però amb estàndards uzbecs, sí.
Però, bueno, m'ho deixen bastant bé.
Mireu el canvi.
Li demano, sisplau, que em deixi gravar aquest moment.
Li dic, això al meu país no es fa.
Un seguidor m'havia advertit per mail que si anava a un barber
és probable que em fessin algun tipus de massatge.
Però aquest era molt prèmium, eh?
Això que té a la mà és un aparell que vibra.
I, doncs això, és un massatge vibrador que em va donar molt de gustillo, eh?
Bon servei.
Uzbekistan, país túrquic.
Què vol dir això?
Doncs que té en airan.
Oh, trobava falta ja l'airan.
I mira, aigua de Borjomi, també.
Això és el poble aquell que vaig passar de les aigües termals allà a Georgia.
Torno a la plaça central i em quedo meravellat.
Meravellat de l'espectacle de llums que tenen aquí, maquíssim,
i de la quantitat de gent que hi ha.
Al migdia no hi havia ningú.
I ara, de cop i volta, tots els uzbecs han sortit
i els guiris passem a ser minoria.
Potser ells no viuen al barri antic, però van a passejar, a caminar, a prendre alguna cosa.
Al barri antic, sí, sí.
Uzbekistan té un clima continental extrem.
De fet, és l'únic país del món, junt amb Liechtenstein,
que està doblement vetat d'una sortida al mar.
És a dir, Uzbekistan no té sortida al mar
i cap país amb els que fa frontera tampoc té sortida al mar.
Això fa que les temperatures siguin molt extremes.
És molt habitual arribar o superar els 40 graus a l'estiu
i a l'hivern baixar dels 0 graus.
I no només hi ha aquesta gran amplitud tèrmica entre estacions,
sinó durant el dia, durant el dia també.
És el contrari que a Barcelona.
El clima és molt, molt sec.
I això fa que a l'ombra, per la nit, doncs s'estigui bé.
S'estigui bastant bé.
Aprofito, doncs, fins ben tard,
fent una volta i menjant un gelat davant d'aquest llac,
amb aquestes llumetes, aquests signes i aquest concert d'aquest senyor.
Us deixo amb algunes imatges més de la nit,
perquè és que era tan maco que no podia deixar de gravar.
Fins demà!
Dia 146 de la volta al món a peu.
Avui, diumenge, dia 2 d'agost.
Aquesta és la genial vista des del meu hotel.
Dos nits, 35 dòlars, amb esmorzar inclòs.
No està mal, no?
No me'l serveixen l'esmorzar fins a les 8.
Jo m'ho hauria aixecat abans,
perquè cal aprofitar aquestes hores que fa menys calor.
Però, bueno, també dorm una mica més.
L'esmorzar, boníssim. Boníssim, boníssim, boníssim.
Tenim aquest embotit de no sé quin animal,
formatge, bastant bo,
fruita, ous, cafè...
Genial.
Què faig avui?
Doncs, bastanta cosa.
Per començar, visito l'arc of Bukhara,
la fortalesa de Bukhara.
És, probablement, el monument més important de la ciutat
i es tractava, aleshores,
d'una enorme ciutadella fortificada
que va servir com a residència
dels emirs de Bukhara
durant més d'un mil·lenni.
Ara potser es veu petit, però al seu dia,
dintre d'aquesta fortalesa
hi havia el palau de l'emir,
les oficines del govern, una mesquita,
on es feien les monedes...
Hi havia una presó
i habitatges per tots els centenars
o milers de treballadors.
Aquestes piles de terra que ocupen
la major part de la superfície de la fortalesa
són resultat del bombardeig
de l'exèrcit roig
que va fer quan va conquistar Uzbekistan.
El que es conserva avui en dia
són les muralles
i alguns edificis que s'han restaurat a posteriori.
Un país que no té mar,
és tot sec,
té quatre rius...
Ostres, està com condemnat, no?
No té cap font de riquesa.
Ara, el turisme.
Però això és fa quatre dies.
Fins fa quatre dies ningú coneixia Uzbekistan.
Doncs dels recursos naturals.
En un d'aquests pocs interessants museus
que hi havia dintre la fortalesa,
ens explica
que Uzbekistan
és el setzè país
amb més reserves de gas del món
i l'exporta sobretot als països veïns,
com la Xina.
I també l'or.
Uzbekistan és un dels deu primers
productors d'or del món.
I home, l'or ha sigut un material
molt valuós
des de sempre.
Què més té Uzbekistan?
Hi ha altres metalls importants
al món avui en dia.
Al passat directe vaig preguntar
què preferiu?
Les postals d'Uzbekistan o de Tajikistan?
Uzbekistan és un país que
no diria que està de moda, però
bastanta gent hi va
dintre del que és l'àsia central.
En canvi, Tajikistan
és un país com més obscur,
quasi ningú va.
Llavors seria més interessant, potser,
tenir la postal de Tajikistan, no?
Vegem per internet
que el servei postal de Tajikistan
és molt poc fiable
i podrien no arribar les postals.
Hi havia divisió d'opinions. Alguns deien
sí de Tajikistan, altres deien
Uzbekistan. Jo crec que
cal prioritzar una mica
el que arribin. El que arribin és el més important.
I per això he comprat
i enviaré les postals
des d'aquí, des d'Uzbekistan.
Però bé, no descarto
fer alguna cosa a Tajikistan, ja us ho diré.
Us vaig dir que necessitava Belgro, no?
Per la placa solar, doncs, aconsegueixo.
Però he d'anar al mercat.
Al mercat on va la gent
normal. Aquí no hi havia ningú turista.
També em compro uns pantalons llargs
per 6 euros. A veure,
la meva idea és que
al Pamir, a la Xina i al nord de Pakistan
faci fred.
Llavors crec que necessitaré uns pantalons
llargs. No els tenia perquè
els anteriors els vaig enviar a casa. Llavors,
bé, aquests em serviran per dos mesos
i ja està. No em compro res.
Perí de coses de street food
i penso que em timen
perquè, perquè
dic, quant costa? I em diuen 50.000.
Que això són 4 euros.
I tu diràs, home, Enric, això no és gaire.
No, no, és molt poc. Però pels estàndards
uzbeks, doncs, és bastant.
Però dic, bueno, tu, no passa res.
Que em timin i que es guanyin una mica
la vida, no passa res. Però resulta que s'havien
equivocat de
parlar l'anglès i no volia dir
50.000, volia dir 15.000.
Així que crec que
per on va costar això. Què més?
Aconsegueixo imprimir les etiquetes
per les postals. Molt bé.
I després acabo comprant
més postals. Perquè,
bueno, em faltaven, havien de comprar
unes 500 i pico.
I molt barates. 100 dollars americans,
com podeu veure, he pagat per unes
500 postals, més o menys,
cap a l'hotel a fer feina. Després
de la migdiada torno per
visitar la mascrita principal de la ciutat.
Veieu aquesta torre d'aquí?
És un minaret. Minaret
molt diferent dels que estem habituats
a veure, especialment, doncs mira,
a Turquia, que he estat ara fa poc.
Aquest minaret, doncs, molt més espectacular.
De fet, quan Gengis Khan
va arribar a la ciutat,
va destruir-la tota excepte
aquest minaret, perquè va dir, mira,
m'agrada, em sembla
guapo, el deixarem intacte.
I així, més o menys, s'acaben aquests
dos dies a Bukhara.
Val la pena venir?
Sí. No és un turisme
de...
de diversió.
M'explico, és un turisme cultural,
de visitar
aquestes ciutats de la Ruta de la Seda,
gaudir del menjar,
que està bastant bo. Sense ser
la millor cuina del món, jo
estic gaudint bastant.
I, sobretot, a mi, el que m'està agradant més
és el fet de sentir-me
a un altre món.
És tan diferent
Europa, això.
És que no té res a veure.
La Posta de Sol, avui, la torno a veure
des de la fortalesa
de Bukhara, perquè el tiquet
et serveix per tot el dia, i tens vistes
a una banda la ciutat
i a l'altra banda la Posta de Sol.
Per cert, em trobo a un altre català,
el Roger,
i anem a sopar
i a fer una birra. Bona nit.
Bona nit.